mais quelques semaines je vous reparler
de motorola motorola qui a fait son
grand retour en france son grand retour
en europe et son rôle tourner le général
or je vous l'avais déjà dit j'ai été
surpris d'ailleurs motorola fonctionne
toujours bien en amérique mérite du nord
amérique du sud et ici c'est un peu plus
difficile alors notre rôle est revenu
avec des produits des produits
intéressants je fais déjà parlé de
motorola par le passé et là ils
reviennent avec une proposition qui est
intéressante avec deux nouveaux
smartphones
on parle donc si ces smartphones sont
intéressants il s'agit ici est bien dû
g50 il s'agit ici de l'aimant boîte du
jeu son ouïe énorme boîte parce qu'à
l'intérieur vous avez un dock on va
regarder tout ça on va regarder ce qu'on
peut faire avec sedan qu'on va regarder
si ces deux smartphones sont
intéressants et si au final le retourne
au taureau l'aï réussie
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs bonne nouvelle motorola
vous offre votre g50 pour repartent à
rivehaute g50 c'est très facile je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description c'est un petit jeu vous
participez et vous serez peut-être
l'heureux ou l'heureuse possesseurs de
ce g 50
bonne chance à tous regardez ça c'est
vrai que cette boîte et les énormes la
boîte du g100 elle fait pas semblant
mais elle est intéressant c'est qu'à
côté du ch et 50 alors ça c'est une
taille de boîtes de smartphones un peu
classique
gardez votre g50 regarder votre gestion
au delà des boîtes au delà on peut faire
avec et du ready for qu'on vous présente
très rapidement derrière ce plutôt
intéressant parce qu'on peut faire on
vient de positionner on utilise comme un
petit air pour un moniteur
on guettera tout à l'heure on a donc
deux nouveaux smartphones qui sont
intéressants pourquoi parce qu'il
symbolise le grand retour de motorola en
france avec deux produits
angers 50 vous avez les fameux logo
derrière la batwing de motorola c'est
les ailes de la chauve souris car un peu
la chauve souris mais c'est pas trop mon
truc et donc vous avez ce fameux logo
batwing à l'arrière alors lui en fait il
fait office de capteur empreintes
digitales c'est assez mal à esquiver
note écrit alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les capteur d'empreintes
digitales ou des smartphones ça se fait
plus trop mais là on ayant intégré le
logo à l'intérieur et bien ça reste
discret ça reste pratique ça reste
élégant donc vous positionnez votre
doigt dessus vous déverrouillez
rapidement ces pratiques se sentent pas
ça marche bien ce qu'on va retrouver
effectivement alors sur le g55 on va le
reconnaît tout de suite c'est un menton
qui est quand même assez grand ici vous
avez cette petite petites encoches sur
le côté on va retrouver sur le g50 votre
bouton pour l'allumer potton bouton de
volume est ici un bouton pour
l'assistant google
trois caméras l'arrière ok on a déjà
parlé de la fiche technique donc je vous
passe très rapidement là dessus et je
vous invite à venir découvrir la vidéo
de présentation de ses smartphones pour
connaître la fiche technique et les
grandes ambitions de motorola derrière
ces smartphones donc voilà pour le 50 et
le g100 c'est pareil on l'avait déjà
regarder là vous avez un effet un petit
peu de poisson en effet un peu irisé
avec ce ce reflet sympa ici de 14 ans
près du seuil se situe sur la tranche il
ya un truc est très marrante
je trouve que les boutons sont un petit
peu au donc pour venir l'utiliser
correctement il faut venir monter sa
main et venir se positionner comme ça la
vôtre 14 empreintes digitales des
dérouille rapidement et ça marche bien
vous avez accès à votre bouton de volume
ici et là juste en haut là vous appuyez
et vous avez accès à votre bouton pour
me rappeler google
alors il faut des grandes mains
potentiellement si vous voulez le tenir
comme ça il faut les très grandes mains
sinon il faut que c'était de guerre
position
et ça m'a plu aux pour utiliser son
bouton pour rappel google si ce temps
pour venir régler le volume
c'est une question d'habitude ici mais
ça que le smartphone est assez long on a
également un petit menton sur le bas ici
mais moins proéminent que sur le g 50 et
puis surtout vous avez ici deux petites
caméras qui sont planqués en haut et ça
c'est plutôt rigolo
maintenant le gros point fort de ses
smartphones eh bien ça va être que
l'autonomie on a exactement les mêmes
batteries d'un côté et de l'autre grosse
batterie de 5000 milliampères heures la
différence avec la charge sans g50
pouvez charger jusqu'à 15 watts mais
vous avez un chargeur de 10 watts inclus
tandis que sur le g100 vous avez un
chargeur de 20 watts inclus bon ok ça
marche ce qui fait que si vous cherchez
un smartphone qui va vous emmener loin
en terme d'autonomie et que sans qu'elle
vous allez pouvoir venir conter en vous
disant vas tiens je pars aujourd'hui je
vais pas forcément accès à un endroit
pour venir dans chargé et bien là-haut -
paf vous êtes pena frottements
extrêmement important vis reconnaître
ici c'est la différence de free sur le
g50 vous êtes à paf 249 euros tandis que
sur le g100 et bien vous êtes à 549
euros iliad aux 300 euros qui sépare ses
modèles
un autre point fort au niveau de ses
smartphones ça va être la performance on
s'en doutera on ira moins loin sur gesse
un compte que sur les 100 et sur nos
stades dragonne 480 processeurs 5g et de
l'autre côté vous avez 1 870 cinq jets
d'eau franchement une bête de compet ça
tourne vous avez 4 64 ici et là vous
avez 828 dans les deux cas vous monté
jusqu'à 1 tera ok ça marche et en plus
ce qui est super bien sûr le descend si
vous avez de la lp dernière 5 techno
drame qui marche super bien qui va très
vite et vous avez du stockage on ne le
fais trois points autant vous dire que
ça va vite ça écrivit de sel leavitt
vous avez de la fluidité un smartphone
qui est extrêmement performant donc si
vous voulez une expérience premium avec
un smartphone à 549 euros
et bien ici en termes de performances au
niveau de l'autonomie le g100 fera la
faire maintenant il ya un point qui est
un peu en dessous c'est ce qu'on va
retrouver au niveau des écrans sur les
deux smartphones lors nous explique le
g5 ans qui peut le faire souffrir c'est
ce qu'on va retrouver la concurrence et
si votre écran c'est du hd plus vous
n'avez pas de full hd vous êtes quand
même
249 euros ça c'est un élément vraiment à
prendre en compte quand on regarde ce
qui se passe du côté de la concurrence
le point positif ici c'est collé sur un
écran 90's donc effectivement ça c'est
bien un écran 90 s avec eux un switch
intelligente du 90 et du 60 hertz pareil
sur le g100 sait si vous êtes sur du
full hd + ok ça fonctionne bien on est
sur du lcd à 549 euros c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait s'attendre et six à avoir une
dalle oled c'est pas le cas ici on sera
unique
sur du lcd audouin connaître ici sur les
deux smartphones vous avez un haut
parleur mono ici sur le banc assez
puissant donc si vous voulez coûté
quelque chose comme ça la main et bien
vous pouvez le faire vous n'avez pas
d'expérience de spatialisation de
stéréoscopie mais vous êtes sur du mono
ok ça fonctionne maintenant le point qui
est sympa aussi des deux côtés ça c'est
le point positif est bien c'est que vous
avez une prise jack d'un côté et de
l'autre
donc si vous voulez profiter d'une
expérience au casque filaire est bien
ici vous pouvez le faire aux points qui
est positif et qui est très sympa sur
les deux smartphones c'est qu'ici vous
tournez sur un android
11 tout ce qui est plus simple tout ce
qui est le plus efficace si vous aimez
spies android brut nature simple
efficace et si c'est le cas donc ça
c'est bien alors on va se parler de la
photo la photo ça m'intéresse parce que
ça des usages plus plus plus dans
l'univers des smart ici motorola vos
amis d'un côté trois capteurs de l'autre
côté quatre capteurs alors la différence
vous allez voir que catherine capteurs
ici c'est que vous avez une caméra tough
time of light qui vient mesurer les
distances sur le g100 vous avez un
capteur de 60 qu'adopter c'est un
capteur de 48 mégapixels vous avez de la
macro de tous les côtés sur le geste en
vous avez un ultra grand angle que vous
n'avez pas sur le g 50 et vous avez une
caméra portrait de tous les côtés bon
très standard sur le papier c'est
séduisant mais je vais vous montrer les
résultats en photo vous allez voir on va
commencer les photos avec le g50 la
caméra de celle fille il a un côté un
peu étrange parce que ça me lis
énormément le visage surtout ici sur le
centre niveau du pif il ya un effet qui
est un peu bizarre
sur le reste bon ça semble convenir et
c'est pas trop trop mal on continue ici
c'est très bleu très très bleu et très
froid au niveau des rendus on peut
cependant avoir un sable un point le
plus chaud ici ce n'est pas le cas alors
il faisait pas très beau non plus
mais malgré tout on continue on peut
venir nous met un peu si on le souhaite
hockey et on va pas aller trop trop hein
parce que bon ça ne fonctionne plus mais
ça c'est normal dans cette gamme de prix
là je trouve qu'il a un côté un peu
lisse et globalement au niveau des
photos et vous le voyez si au niveau des
petites vagues on vient vous venez ça
disent davantage pour ça ce n'est pas
plus c'est très très standard et on leur
trouve un petit peu partout et voyez dès
qu'on a un peu trop souvent et ça marche
par la macro les maraudes s'est vraiment
mis les mains dans la fourmilière temps
d'aller chercher les petites images on
peut redécouvrir les fourmis et voir
comment elle fonctionne donc ça c'était
assez assez rigolo à faire alors les
photos de nuit ces juges pas compris
j'ai pas compris la photo de nuit
d'un point de vue algorithmique à ce qui
s'est passé ça cherche à compenser des
choses s'il n'y arrive pas alors une
fois de plus on est sur un smartphone à
249 euros donc
ici voyez on en a pour son argent en
continu et les photos du g100 capteur
principal 5 semble fonctionner c'est pas
trop trop mal lorsque je viens me
rapprocher bien je viens lycée je le
vois ici notamment au niveau des vagues
voyez là ça a cherché un petit peu à
lisser et lorsque je me rapproche
davantage d'un moment ça ne marche pas
et c'est normal on a le double module
photo de celle fille avec le grand-angle
et ultra grand-angle et le résultat je
trouve moins bon que celui du g5 entre
au niveau de la peau c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment too much
et lorsque je passe dans l'ultra grand
temps qu on est vraiment sur autre chose
c'est vraiment pas beau quoi j'ai bon la
caméra principale à l'arrière ça fera le
taf l'ultra grand temps que ça - point
précis et une différence de colorimétrie
mais ça c'est normal dans les
smartphones donc on n'a pas les mêmes
capteurs dont bon rien de bien
surprenant par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
ailleurs et lorsqu'on vient zoomer
davantage salissent évidemment c'est
plus beau de la macro on peut regarder
quelques petites fautes aussi ça
fonctionnera on continue ici je l'emmène
à bord de la mer comme ça en profitant
voyez on voit un petit peu tout ce qui
se passe et la photo nuit ici pour un
smartphone je trouve qu'ils aient à 549
euros
eh ben je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage et c'est pas terrible parce
qu'ils n'y arrivent pas du tout dans
tous les cas vous avez une double vanos
in 5g plus 4g ou na no 6 + carte microsd
jusqu'à un terrain très bien et si en
plus vous avez du wifi si dans tous les
cas vous avez du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé donc ça c'est intéressant
donc voilà le ready for comment ça
marche vous avez votre smartphone qui
est là qui est branché en fait
directement via usb c'est hop là
directement ici en hdmi sur votre télé
je sais pas si vous le voyez bien donc
ce qui est sympa c'est que vous pouvez
venir complètement l'enlever pour le
positionner dans un sens ou dans un
autre c'est aimante et ça marche bien
donc en fonction de ce que vous allez
regarder ce que vous allez faire
eh bien vous le positionner comme vous
voulez et là vous l'avez directement sur
votre télé vous choisissez vous avez
soit bureau mobile soit téléviseur soit
je sois chat vidéo aux sphères bureau
mobile par exemple
donc là on fait ça vous fait un bureau
et là vous venez bouger ça et ça vous
sert de trackpad
donc vous pouvez même le poser à plat et
ensuite choisissez sur ce que vous
voulez aller reconnaît par exemple si
vous venez ouvrir crom donc là vous avez
votre navigateur chrome vous pouvez
venir utiliser naviguer avec très
facilement vous allez retrouver toutes
vos applications ici avec lesquels des
points à venir jouer lorsque vous voulez
faire de la recherche
le truc qui est pratique ici en fait
c'est que vous pouvez venir prendre une
petite manette et venir jouer à des jeux
directement sur votre téléviseur à
partir votre smartphone donc ça vous
sert de petites consoles ça vous sert de
périphériques pour venir faire de la
bureautique avec un petit clavier
bluetooth ya pas mal de petits
h derrière tout ça pour le coup vraiment
très pratique et là j'avoue faire du
mais roaring très facilement j'ai accès
à tous mes paramètres donc toute
l'expérience que je peux avoir ici avec
ceux des crédits fort et un cru pour le
tarif de 149 euros
donc ça veut dire que j'utilise mon
smartphone non pas que comme un
smartphone mais lorsque je suis en
déplacement
eh bien je sens que j'ai une télé dans
un hôtel et bien je peux l'utiliser pour
venir travailler
lorsque je suis chez moi je peux
utiliser comme un centre de
divertissement pour venir partager du
contenu également donc ça pour le coup
je dois reconnaître que c'est aussi
assez intéressant ces smartphones
ils sont intéressants si vous ne voulez
pas un smartphone chinois si vous voulez
un produit amérique si vous voulez
effectivement le ready for avec le g100
ils seront très bon au niveau de
l'autonomie donc si vous voulez un
smartphone endurant vous ne serez pas
déçus et si vous voulez un smartphone
qui va bien que très performant
notamment avec le g100 ici et sur sa
dragonne 870 à 549 euros
eh bien ça marche bien ses smartphones
ils sont intéressants mais aussi des
points un peu trop négatifs à savoir la
photo au niveau des capteurs principaux
ça ira mais dès qu'on relâche un peu
plus loin c'est tout de suite moins ça
on peut venir discuter des technologies
sur les écrans entre le oled et le lcd
ce qui est sûr c'est que la calibration
n'est pas parfaite ils sont pas mauvais
mais c'est vrai que par rapport à ce
qu'on peut trouver à la concurrence il
ya un petit truc qui manque alors ses
smartphones moi je trouve malgré tout
intéressant ce parce que je trouve
intéressant c'est le retour de motorola
avec une nouvelle image avec une
nouvelle campagne de publicité beaucoup
plus jeunes gens ça hyper sexy et vraie
volonté au niveau des équipes de
motorola de venir dynamiser la marque
devenir la booster il reste quelques
petits points à venir affiné au niveau
des dit vas y ça ça vient effectivement
on est vous des états unis donc il faut
que les us viennent bosser un peu cette
copie pour que enfin motorola puisse
arriver est extrêmement percutant dit
pas ce que vous en pensez vous en bas on
commentaires comment vous les trouvez
c'est motorola cg50 cg100 intéressant
par intéressant ce qu'il vous botte vous
botte pas quels sont les points qui vous
intéresse ou ceux qui vous rebute
marquer ma tout ça bien évidemment en
bas en commentaire quand on se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler avec
des bijoux des mots pour les soins de
chaos